for me reinvention is really focused on
idat it's being able to take what really
is commercially off-the-shelf products
bring them together to provide real
solutions that never were possible which
is exactly what we've done in my company
of beating Vinod Technologies
[Music]
about ten years ago a friend of mine
went down with cardiac arrest and we
called the organ a tional guard to come
rescue him when the helicopter arrived
the basket that they were lowering down
to us below was swinging back and forth
unable to get through the trees and
after multiple attempts they eventually
called off the mission and we called
time of death
[Music]
we took that problem and then once the
military and said is this a systemic
problem across all search and rescue
operations and a factor was 24 people
every single day are either killed or
injured because of it and so basically
we went out and said how can we solve
this and we tried to figure out okay can
we take a rail system and put it on the
side of the helicopter to try and
mitigate the swing of a Blackhawk or try
and manipulate the hovering system of a
helicopter both really stupid ideas I
mean I started in 2012 and I was 18
years old just started an undergrad and
no one believed me worth a crap I was
too young I was 18 you have no idea what
you're talking about these are the DoD
this is the military this is the
Lockheed Martin's the Boeing's of the
world that made absolutely no sense just
get out and that's exactly what it was
until 2018 we had nothing and we just
continued to struggle bus it for years
upon years upon years and then finally
when I was 25 we were able to actually
build something which was basically a
black box with red fans that we said all
it turns on but then we put it on a
Robinson 44 aircraft and actually said
oh wait it actually can do something and
then that's when it hit
[Music]
every investor every the military the US
Air Force the US Army all came together
basically saying holy crap you've got
something it doesn't matter that you're
26 years old doesn't matter that you're
able to have this kind of thing and
actually face the Giants that are the
big OMS of the world but it's now hey
how do you take this ideation and then
execute on it how do you roll it out and
that's exactly where everybody started
to jump on the team because now it moved
from disbelief to belief and that was
the most empowering thing that I could
possibly imagine
normally in today's society people are
going to tell you the three common
things especially in startups
perseverance willingness to fail courage
all that kind of stuff but for me it was
legacy legacy is what made it all
worthwhile but more importantly kept me
focused on exactly where I needed to go
in order to execute the mission which is
to bring those people
you